hi before we start let me acknowledge
that this video was made in
collaboration with an Academy which is
the India's biggest learning platform
connecting educators and students all
across India now when I was a student I
had always a big problem remembering the
name of the filament especially vitamin
b-complex I mean it's not necessary but
from an exam point of view or a
competitive exam point of view it is so
important but you can always google it
right in real life somehow we have to
remember the names and what are their
functions and it is always confusing so
in this video we would learn about a
trick which we can use to remember this
thing and apply that and it would give
you a hundred percent success so let's
just not bother further and in next two
minutes let's look at the trick so in
order to understand the trick you have
to first look at which exams actually
ask questions from vitamin B's section
and all so first list is the IDM
biotechnology in that particular this
particular question asked to match
between two columns where one column
there is named vitamin b1 b2 b2 etc etc
another column there are names of
coenzymes that are associated with these
vitamins or the format of these vitamins
which is served as he served as a two
enzyme right so in order to understand
you have to have a mnemonic ready so
let's go to the mnemonic let me
introduce you to the famous vampire II
so she's queen pant body or known as
Ronny band pairi and her favorite food
is bio fully corn cob by the way she's
known as Ronnie pump Irie because she
has a pan in her hand and she always
liked to cook and her favorite food is
by offal eat corn cob so let me crack
down the mnemonic write down the
vitamins from b12 b12 in sequence like
this and rhyme this
the Ronnie pen pairi cooks bio fully
corn cob remember that cooks and corn is
silent now this mnemonic is basically
the names of the vitamins the Ronnie
right the means timing RAF or riboflavin
means neo seen and pan pairi pan is
pantothenic acid remember Danny pan
Barry always had a pen in her hand
Tyree is pyridoxine and this special
corn which is a bio fully corn cob is
actually biotene folic acid and Kabbalah
mean Kabbalah meanies bremen p12
now let's take again two minutes to
understand what at the name of the
coenzymes from derived from these
vitamins now we already introduced you
to run deep and peri and you know what
she wants to eat a weird thing like the
bio fully corn cob and it's not easy to
digest so she needs stuff for digestion
always remember Danny pant body needs
fat natkho enzyme to digest that
[ __ ] so the mnemonic is the fat
natkho enzyme pirate took to digest by a
fully corn cob so clear
two things first you have to understand
that what pan Pilar used to like and
what she used to cook and second thing
what she used to digest that by ophélie
corn cob now here it is designed in such
a way Dom means thiamine pyrophosphate
is pyrophosphate fat nad is basically fa
d f MN or nad nad p coenzyme a is Gwen's
I'm a fat nad coenzyme a now coenzyme a
is basically derived from pantothenic
acid then Pyrrha means by de Doxil
phosphate which is derived from vitamin
b6 then bio fully concur pretty much
human the same bio for biotene falling
for tetrahydrofolate and cob for dioxide
missile cobalamin and this
deoxyadenosine cobalamin does not go
like that with this mnemonic
but you can think this enzyme is used
for
detoxing the corncob so that's how you
can remember deoxy adenosylcobalamin now
let's look at the question that is asked
in IT champ 2018 here is it look at this
and now try to remember the mnemonic the
Ronnie pan Polly used to cook by ophélie
corncob and the fat nad co-enzyme pirate
took to digest by a fully corn cob that
immediately gives you the answer so you
know thea mean pyrophosphate is from
vitamin b1 riboflavin or riboflavin
which is vitamin b2 the coenzyme format
is flavin mononucleotide or FMN way to
mean b5 is basically giving rise to
pyridoxine and vitamin b6 is a pile
rocks well phosphate now you can clearly
understand which is the correct option
right now that's great right so if you
want more such tricks that would Neela a
tea jam I have a crash course online
going on in Akutan Academy from December
1st now the page is not yet uploaded but
it would be updated soon I hope to see
you guys there and this crack I teach
amber technology I hope you enjoyed this
video if you like this video give it
thumbs up and don't forget to like share
and subscribe and stay tuned thank you